Guess who's back, back again... Grace is back. Please, god damn it, tell your friends
(Oh no)
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
On Tuesday, I put up a video where I tried to recreate Taco Bell chicken quesadillas
In my research process for looking up Taco Bell menu recipes
the number one thing that came up was a
Crunchwrap Supreme
Bought all the ingredients for it in case the chicken quesadillas went bad...
chicken quesadillas went...
cliffhanger! If you want to find out, go watch my last video!
But then I had all the ingredients, so last week
I ended up making Crunchwrap Supremes
and it turned out kind of okay. Taco Bell is basically just like a salt mush trough with some crunch occasionally.
So I thought let's just roll with the momentum and make another Taco Bell menu item this week.
I got this recipe from: Delish.com. I'll put the link in the description box below
Let's make this Crunchwrap Supreme, shall we?
You have no choice... we're doing it.
I'm feeling confint about this... confident!
You know someone's really confident when they struggle to pronounce the word...
So in a skillet over medium heat,
we're gonna add some ground beef, some chili powder, some paprika, and some cumin.
We're gonna cook it, they say like 5 minutes
then we're gonna drain all the fat oils out of it, and add some salt and pepper.
So now we need flour tortillas
and tostadas, which are basically just flat, crunchy tortillas.
I was supposed to get large flour tortillas, but I think I got like a medium-sized
I probably should have got a bigger size...
So you're supposed to take your tostada, put it on top of your tortilla, and cut around...
*music plays*
There! A tortilla and a tostada! Put those to the side...
Then we're gonna build our Crunchwrap!
So we're gonna take another large flour tortilla. Lay it down, add a scoop of the ground beef
this is where I go wrong and always overpack it...
Leave a generous space around the edge, because that's what you're gonna fold up.
I gotta make sure my pan is on slightly hot with some oil.
Then we're gonna take our cheese sauce
put some drizzles of that on...
*music plays*
Cute! Perfect! There we go! Then we put the tostada shell on top.
I'm gonna clip it around the edges a little bit...
Do a quick haircut....
Then we're gonna put sour cream on top of this.
Why do they make food that's bad for you, like, so gross to open?
Oh, so you think about it?
Sour cream!
Okay, then I put lettuce... I didn't have lettuce but I had cabbage in my refrigerator, so we're using cabbage.
Everything's a little bit gonna be bad... tomatoes!
Then you're supposed to put some shredded cheddar and some shredded Monterey Jack cheese on
I had cheddar jack and mexican style cheese...
It's all a slop trough and nothing's better than anything else.
So whats gonna happen now, and this is the part I'm so bad at, and I tried to practice...
The cut out that we did of the tostada shape, we're gonna put on top
and then we're gonna slowly start to fold our bottom tortilla around
and then we're just gonna try and shove it in the pan as fast as we can so it doesn't fall apart.
But you know... guess what... it's gonna fall apart... All right...
F***! I f***ked this up!
They make it look so easy in their video! I highly encourage you to watch it.
F*** it, we've folded it enough... here we go.
Oh f***, we f***ed this up so hard... going to fold it.
Oh! Ow!
Oh when it fell apart immediately... Why did I even try to do this beforehand?
Wanna see this? Look...
This is the saddest Crunchwrap Supreme. I'm so sad and for some weird reason it smells like fish and I don't know why....
So you're supposed to cook it seam side down for three to five minutes
and then turn it over and cook it another three to five minutes.
I'm gonna try to make another one to redeem myself.
*music plays*
My children!
Here are all the Crunchwrap Supremes that made because couldn't stop! I made three of them...
You can see my first attempt, my second attempt, and my third attempt
which I'm honestly super proud of, because I think it looks the most like Crunchwrap Supreme.
But the sad part is that it takes Taco Bell like, I don't know, 45 seconds to make this thing
and this took me about an hour and a half... let's see if it tastes the same!
Hot sauce!
Do you see this little thing? It's literally like she knows the one place that she can sit... ok sorry
I found you out! The one place that she can sit in the corner when she's in frame
and it's like she reads your comments and gets your sympathy.
Cheers!
Yeah! Yeah! It's just a salt trough! That's all it is, and it's delicious!
Just one more for good measure.
Yeah! Did it! Thank you Delish!
I don't know what the moral is here... getting Taco Bell is so easy to do.
Making it at home is way harder.
It gives you way more time to think through like what you're doing
so if you wanna live that kinda life... try this.
Don't forget to subscribe to my YouTube channel, if you haven't already!
I'm consistently inconsistent! So hit that bell notification so you know when I post videos
because I don't even know.
I don't know...
I'm just gonna eat it, cause that's how you eat Taco Bell
you don't question the formality, and you don't question the what emotional state led you here.
Also, definitely don't question the emotional state that led you to create
your own Taco Bell at home.
*loud noise*
That's my bug zapper. Oh! All of these are sad sentences that I'm saying!